Justin and a few weeks ago we've checked
out Guitar Hero live but today they
showed us Qatar hero TV this is a whole
new area this is almost like what you
would consider just extra DLC on top of
the final game once you buy it it comes
with all this extra stuff including two
channels that are just streaming the
entire time and a whole bunch more yet
we've been wondering for a long time how
exactly is this gonna work because
they've been talking about from the
beginning they're gonna be hundreds of
songs you're gonna have some amount of
it on disc and some amount of it will be
available outside of that and now we
have a much clearer picture even though
we don't quite know how pricing is gonna
work and we'll talk about what would be
good for that a little bit later but
thinking about like here's what you have
on disc and here is the content that you
get outside of that and it's gonna be
across two channels like you get to play
this on it's like watching old school
and TV win you know women play music and
you're gonna watch music videos and you
could just play those songs as they
happen but it's almost like a completely
different game because it has its own
system of leveling it has songs that are
not on the disc
I would this view guys yeah this is the
multiplayer mode to the tiger live
single planet and this is the thing that
is the big hook for I mean the whole
like people looking at you stuff that's
cool bit yeah this is a different way to
play the game and I thought it was
really cool because I mean I like to
play loud guitar and to be able to
switch on and just have songs thrown at
me constantly was a really nice idea
yeah being able to access that DLC as an
old-school rock band guitar hero player
I've paid a lot of money for DLC over
the years and I don't always play it
that much like maybe I'll download that
song and it's like 2 or 3 dollars and
like that's the one time I play it here
you're just you have constant access to
two songs maybe like maybe you don't get
to play them whenever you want but
they're but they're playing and you get
you're getting that constant stream of
song so it's more like it said to play
get new like new shots to actually try
and hit you know like something you
might not want to buy you know straight
away you can play it once or twice I
mean it's a nice like try before you
know commit to it you don't have to
commit to anything
there's a lot more content in addition
to these two channels as well they're
giving us competitions we can play
online with people consistently there's
weekly challenges now where they might
ask you to get 100 notes streak on a
very particular song and then that will
unlock certain things so they've been
really interested in showing off skins
so there's particular skins for each of
your guitar is no truck you're no tracks
and so when you're playing it and
they're very specific right like some
really interesting ones that are that
make you feel really unique so there's
there's all these like nice incentives
to it yeah but I think something that's
really new that we got to check out
today was the leveling system this is
really interesting this is kind of we
were calling the call of duty of Guitar
Hero because you actually are unlocking
things so there are huge benefits to
leveling up now when you think about how
getting onto the onto the top tracks
beating your friends is something that
it's always a core part of those
experiences like a rock band and Guitar
Hero like I want to do better than my
than everybody else and this one you
actually have to keep playing you have
to level up in a very Call of Duty like
way or else even to people who are on
equal footing the person who has leveled
up lore is gonna have more skills more
abilities for their guitars and they're
gonna do better so like some of the
abilities we saw were and instead of
leveling up your guitar where you get a
regular amount of points for it for
notes you can actually get like one
point to level up to the next point you
get one point four times the points for
every note the hit but you also get
different abilities there in different
hero powers I think is what they call
the new stuff yeah so like yeah they're
like some really odd ones that would
change the game like you would get more
chances to get even more star power like
you can thanks star power now I'm sorry
hero power and save two for like a
really difficult section there's there
was that bomb one that you could
activate and just blow up the entire
track in front of you and get the
perfect score for that that section and
it seems a bit of a powder at first
because you know when you're competing
on a leaderboard you know that's a bit
unfair and unbalanced but you know we
were told that once you hit the prestige
level so to speak everything will be
equal weight less you have to get up to
that prestige level first and it can be
I think when you hear about it it feels
like oh this is giving people an unfair
advantage
but in it but it's worth pointing out
that those here are powers the the
abilities for your guitar can only be
unlocked with the in-game currency that
you own like there is two types of
currency there's the real world money
the in-game currency and everything in
the game you can access through in-game
currency it's a little bit different in
and how often and how much you can
access it but everything you can see
that you can purchase with real world
money you can get with in-game money
they have been a little shaky with how
much they've actually told us about this
money how much everything's going to
cost when you want to play a song you
can just have a play you can use a play
is what they call it and it costs one
play to play a song once you don't get
it again you lose that play and you earn
that just by playing songs let's say say
you're playing through the free channels
yeah each time you play a song and those
free channels you're earning currency
that you can redeem for plays then you
can play this song for free then you can
also buy the song with in-game currency
or you can use your real money to buy
these songs that way you have them
unlocked forever and now there's another
tier where it's subscription or
unlocking for a certain amount of time
let's say 12 hours so I want to have a
party and I want have my friends over
and I want everything unlocked I don't
want to worry about it you can either
spend in-game currency or use real game
currency to just unlock all the content
for 12 hours and that's pretty
interesting but we don't know how much
any of this stuff is going to cost you I
mean the system itself is it seems
really great like you know I play a lot
of guitar and you know if I can access
all this content without you know having
to pay money and just like hang out in a
channel for a day like that's really
exciting but yeah that casual sort of
player who plays only 40 hours each day
that price would be a big deal breakup
well I think the thing that gets really
off-putting is when you describe
something as free like when you think of
something as free but then there's a
paywall to it like that automatically
feels it get cost more money but we paid
for a DLC for rock band yeah and Guitar
Hero for a long time and like what two
dollars a song yeah and that's that's
kind of a premium when you think I think
I own iTunes you can get us on for a
dollar right and and also now when we're
putting plays into the mix too I mean
how much is a play going to cost when
I'm only going to play the song once and
what if I spend the
50 cents or $1 whatever for this play
and then my internet craps out or I
don't like it somebody comes over and I
need to answer the door
you know or you gotta go to the bathroom
I'm like did you lose that money you
just lose it it's gone and so you you
get yourself into this very weird gray
area where how are people going to
actually feel when they're spending real
real-world money this very different
scenario when you're playing it 4-1
times you don't know if you can still
get all of that content for free like
you don't get reward you for yeah hi and
then and that's what's important to me
as someone who's gonna play a lot of the
game the fact that I'm getting something
out of it that I can access that content
without it and they've described it as
two currencies but as we keep saying
like how many plays do you get how do
you earn plays that's technically a
third currency and like then it's gonna
be really important that you were able
to earn those quickly that we're able to
get access to them like if I get a play
for every regular song that I play like
that that would feel really worth it
there's so much to go into here that we
haven't barely expressed the surface of
what what Guitar Hero TV is right
because now with these unlockable things
there's going to be challenges before
you can actually get to your main
challenge right so there's like these
three boxes of tiers of things you have
to do maybe like get three stars on a
song get a hundred note streak on
another song and if you don't have those
songs unlock you're gonna to use your
plays to get to the songs so that you
can unlock the main things so there's
there's a lot to this o or if those
songs come up in a playlist you can also
earn them through that so like as long
as that premium content is available to
unlock you can try to complete the
challenge to get to it or you can always
just pay real-world money to get to it
right away there's there is a lot that
we don't know yet until we understand
the price structure and that's something
that they said they're going to be
figuring out probably up until the last
minute there's there's a lot that we
don't know yet and also even you know
the menu systems that we saw they're
still figuring out a lot of this stuff
they're still figuring out what the
challenges are gonna be what the prizes
will be so there's still a lot to
uncover but we got our first chance out
of looking at it and I'll tell you if
there's anything that's really amazing
about it it's just being able to hang
out
with a bunch of friends and to have an
actual NTV in the background
for the first time to like see the music
videos in the background this is like
what we were saying it's a Call of Duty
meets MTV when it was cool